one might be useful to say things as
percentages rather than I just want to
go around they don't if I've got okay
let me pose this little situation to you
well suppose I told you there was a
country and it had exactly eleven
million women in the country who did a
census okay and that's how many women we
found okay yeah do you think that's
unusual or normal okay because there who
thinks it's unusual okay all right thank
you
now I'm interested unfortunately at the
time I was gonna ask you why I'm gonna
ask you why you thought it was normal or
unusual that truth is no it's usually as
I said to you the country was Australia
okay the Australia do you know how many
people there are about twenty Tyrion I
looked it up I think it's witty 2.6 or
something like that
now I just said twenty three million I'm
just gonna go capital in the mood okay
what percentage of that twenty two
million are women what percentage you
can get your calculator out and you can
check it's about heart
right what is the number you'd go eleven
over twenty three wouldn't you 11
divided by twenty three then you
multiply by 100 to get your percentage
makes me decimal and what you get so
it's just a banana huh that sounds noble
okay but alternatively if I told you no
no it wasn't Australian I was talking
about it was Japan they don't know what
the relation in Japan is like we need a
ballpark
it's about about 128 million now what
percentage is of the population Japan
these women if I told you there were 11
million what is it
you calculator huh and you say 11
divided by 128 8.6 sir do you see now
why having quantities as a percentage
are actually tremendous why are useful
why why percentages in this case boy
what is it about this situation that
makes percentages hey yeah that's good
right so when you just say 11 million
you need to find out more about the
situation to know whether it's weird
well normal okay once you find out this
then you learn but on the other hand if
I gave you the percentage then you can
immediately tell I think that's okay
whoa what's going on there okay all of
the all the women have just you know got
on a mass exodus from the country